[Music]
I know I've been working for a thousand
years but I've been working really hard
it's not all just like relaxing and
eating donuts but my wandering nose was
the baby's gender which we're so excited
saying that we don't care what the
gender is my goal was to push into the
pink straps back a little bit of a big
blue there well pregnant Amy Schumer
giving fans that tease and a plug for
upcoming Netflix comedy special growing
meanwhile Jessica Simpson as growing
showing and oversharing and we're loving
every minute as she dropped a new list
of hashtag pregnancy problems a broken
toilet seat y'all yep that happened last
night Jess posted the hilarious photo
proof and the warning don't lean back on
the toilet when pregnant but don't worry
this soon-to-be mom of three kept relax
here and the brand-new nearly $400 sleep
recliners she bought to help with her
severe acid reflux just because of
stress and anxiety I feel like it's good
to walk and not just like lay there I
mean I can I can lay there in binge
watch TV for sure but I feel better if
I'm out with the kids and walking around
there's no doubt jess is having a
difficult pregnancy her swollen feet
found relief thanks to cupping just
called them skank holes skinny ankles my
feet were so swollen I was like I mean
what do people do to like deflate in
this post just shared she took a walk in
the rain to fight insomnia she also had
a month of sciatica pain followed by
three weeks of bronchitis we know jess
is naming her baby girl Bertie and
another thing we know one of her fashion
must-haves are these $790 bindi slides
last week the 38 year old confessed the
one thing that gets me through this
pregnancy is knowing I will get another
one of these cuties
[Music]